[Musique]
tout de suite on va passer à la cabine
adoptent ces partiques amis là bas
[Applaudissements]
vous allez regarder ce qu'il y a ce
qu'il ya derrière derrière chaque
cabinet laissait rien contre jean michel
maire qui a une mauvaise où il va
choisir une des deux cabinets va devoir
embrasser la personne qui vient derrière
la cabine c'est bon franck et malik et
ouais moi je crois que tu déconnes et
allons même la non pardon alors c'est
jean michel maire qui mâchouille
attention et je peux pas moi y'a les
plus tôt moi je vois mon père j'ai fait
des erreurs j'ai péché vous prenez ça
allait aller où ils gagnent trop bien
sûr oui prenez pas garde
rangayen ou froch non je comprends qu on
va voir tout de suite ce qu'il y avait
derrière l'ancien rideau de gad
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gardez sabrina qui s'ouvrirait qui a
décrit la à une bombe de meuf
non non elle est magnifique ouais garde
oui quoi des courbes des courbes
d'audience ouais j'ai l'âme et sa red
bull à gad gamme
alors attendez on va voir d'ailleurs
lorsqu'il avait derrière francs
allongement
et d'ailleurs quand les gens portent son
nom
non je chante bien truc de teulet
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci à toi quoi j'ai vu
du très très lourd vraiment rock et si
vous avez vu ici trop c'est bien ici
c'est bien c'est bien cyril moi j'évite
ce qu'il ya dedans vous allez faire
votre jeu mais j'ai un débrief de ce qui
vient de se passer en jean michel on va
regarder d'abord qu'il y avait ici on a
ouvert le rideau
moi j'étais à la hauteur de gori
[Applaudissements]
toutefois comme un fait ça
même si corinne pas mis d'accord il
merci j'ai adoré le dos
[Musique]